My knitting instructions are telling
me to increase stitches evenly across
the row. In this sample,
I've removed the knitting from the machine
and then I'm rehanging the stitches,
leaving empty needles.
The first method is a hand knitting
technique called knit in the front and back.
It's also called M1 or make one.
Worked this way,
it's a left-leaning increase.
This method is often used
for decorative increases.
It's fiddly to do on the machine.
Pick up the right side of the stitch
with a transfer tool and place that strand
on the empty needle, keeping the original
stitch on its original needle.
You can see how the stitch is twisted.
When it's knit, you can see that the leg
of this increase is leaning left.
Another increase you can use as a standard
machine knitting increase.
Pick up the purl bump of the row below
and fill in the empty
needle for the increase.
As you can see, both of these
methods give very different results.